antigamente a criança não queria comer a
gente enganava a criança para comer come
e tá aqui o blog nem não quero broca
sorvete neném sorvete de coisa de do
Hulk O menino já ia abrir a boca
automático esse ano sem enfiava o bloco
na boca do menino ele mastigar sorvete
né mamãe hoje em dia você não engana
mais cara as crianças a criança evoluiu
de um jeito que não tem mais como você
mentir enganar ela para poder ela parar
de encher seu saco mas é cara quem tem
sobrinho quem tem sabe como é que é vai
pra criança abusar para botar um desenho
vai mãe bato o Pernalonga mãe o
Pernalonga um pernalo perna logo
Pernalonga aí você liga a televisão
botava qualquer papo reto tivesse
passando aí meu filho Pernalonga a
criança fica
hoje em dia Ave Maria eu quero adora
Aventureira eu quero a Dora Aventureira
Aventureiro da Aventura tu bota um
desenho parecido a Sonia Aventureira
isso aí não é não é cara a criança vira